our next presenter was educated in
London and is a graduate of use to UCLA
she produced movies such as the 25th
hour quills and driving lessons and was
the executive producer of the Paris
family and run off presenting the award
to Elizabeth oyebode a is Julia chessmen
oh hello all right this will be worth
waiting for Elizabeth oh yeah bday there
she is it's not just luck that I
pronounced Elizabeth's name with
confidence she provided a helpful
phonetic spelling and pronunciation
guide in her personal statement to the
cap any o ye a board a her own
confidence was forged over time of
course though born in Washington DC
Elizabeth returned with her family to
Nigeria for a number of years when she
was still very young her parents were a
seamstress and a reverend when they
returned to the DC area a few years
later she found she she had an accent
she had become an immigrant in her own
country struggling to fit in at school
while being bullied by bigger kids who
made fun of her Elizabeth shot back by
imitating their accents and soon she
found her first appreciative audience
she was a big hit she had started to
find her voice between the ropes is set
in the double dutch jump roping program
of an urban elementary school a kind of
inner sanctum for the girls who are
searching for a place they can shine and
feel safe in a tough environment a place
that in her words pulses with vibrant
hope and history but is also riddled
with crime and poverty the story pulls
us in with its mixture of humor and
tragedy and most of all with its sense
of truth the voice of the author shines
through loud and clear I know we will be
hearing a lot more from Elizabeth oh
yeah bday it's my honor to introduce her
to you tonight Elizabeth
first of all I'd like to thank Julia for
wearing heels thank you guys that was
awesome I want to thank Fe and Rodrigo
that was amazing this whole night has
been great um I think I think we watch
films because our curious minds crave
connection higher truths and adventure
films are one of the few things left
that unites us all they literally bring
us together and remind us about empathy
and Wonder and passion and joy and hope
before that film can exist though one of
us in here or out there has to sit down
in front of a blank page or screen and
imagine dream prey occasionally
procrastinate a little bit a lot when I
was a kid I spent a lot of time
daydreaming and as I got older I
discovered I could craft those pictures
in my head those invisible images into
words on a page and that was so
refreshing the world can seem really
daunting at times but there is a freedom
when you're writing when you're painting
and sculpting those words you can go
anywhere you want and you can be whoever
you want my thanks to the Academy to all
the nickel readers to Joan to Greg to
Julia and the rest of the nickel
committee for reminding us never to
limit our stories or ourselves and for
keeping the candle lit for so many of us
all over the world you are the gold
standard and your encouragement keeps us
going I want to thank my other nickel
fellows
and finalists who made the past few
weeks so much fun my family and friends
who came from near and far improv people
any of you guys are in the crowd thank
you for coming to my mom who's here
tonight thank you for showing me what
hard work and perseverance look like and
for always asking how is your writing
with that mix of both suspicion and
support that only but only a Nigerian
mother can pull off and to my love thank
you for reading draft upon draft upon
draft upon draft even though English is
not your first language and for always
saying this is it this is perfect but i
have a few changes thank you guys and i
am so honored to be a nickel fellow you
guys have no idea thank you very much